[MUSIC PLAYING]
Happy December 1 to everybody.
And welcome back to the
Data Science Hangout.
Hope you all had a great week.
Last week, we were
off for Thanksgiving.
And so if you're joining us
for the first time today,
this is an open space for the
whole data science community
to connect and chat about data
science leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to learn about what's
going on in the
world of data science
across different industries.
And we share the recordings
each week to our posit YouTube.
So you can always go
back and rewatch or find
helpful resources.
We are putting them up to our
new posit Data Science Hangout
site.
Just it's taking a little bit
longer, but they will be there.
Together at the
Hangout, we're all
dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment
for everybody here.
So we love when you
all can participate
and we can hear from everyone no
matter your level of experience
or area of work.
And I had a dream
last night that I
forgot to say this part next
and that nobody was talking.
I don't know why
I had this dream.
But there's always three ways to
ask questions and also provide
your perspective.
So it doesn't just
have to be a question
if you have something
you want to weigh in on
or a certain topic, but
one, you can jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom.
Two, you can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you want me to
read it out instead.
It's in the Zoom chat.
And then third, we
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
One more thing, we
also have a Slido--
sorry, a LinkedIn group
for the Hangout, too.
So if this also helps you
connect with each other,
we'll share that in the
chat in a second here.
We've learned that you
do have to manually turn
on the notifications
for the group using
the little bell at the top
if you wanted to do that.
But with all of that, thank you
so much for joining us here.
Happy to be joined by my co-host
for today, Christina Fillmore,
data science leader at GSK.
And Christina, thanks
for joining us here.
I'd love to have you
maybe start by introducing
yourself and sharing a little
bit about your role, maybe
something you like to
do outside of work, too.
OK.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Christina.
Despite my American accent,
I do live in the UK.
I'm not sure if you can
see it, it's dark outside.
So I thought that's my fun fact.
I work at GSK.
And I work within the
biostatistics space.
And one of the main
roles right now
that you see across
a lot of pharma
are pharma moving
into the R space
and starting to use
R as a primary tool
in order to report
clinical trials.
So one of my main
jobs today is actually
just writing a lot
of our packages
for our specific needs.
Pharma does a lot of things
that are very pharma,
that are just like, if it--
whether it comes from
doing things like the way
we format tables
and create tables.
Pharma does stuff that most--
most of the times, you
don't do things like--
just in the world of
tables, because that's
my most recent package.
So I can talk all about
tables and table design
as interesting and exciting
as that is to anybody--
is things like we tend
to make mock tables.
We make a fake version
of the table we
want before we have any data.
And then we use
that fake version
to make the table we want
much later down the line.
But oftentimes, the fake
version of the table
happens six months to
a year or even more,
depending on how long your
study is to making that table.
So doing things that make
it so that it's easier
to work through
the pharma pipeline
and allow for automation
while making our packages
is basically my job, which is
really long winded way to say,
I make our packages.
But that is what I do.
And I think that was
all your question.
My last question was what is
a hobby I have outside of work
and I would say knitting.
I knit this jumper.
I like knitting.
That's awesome.
Cool.
I was debating if
I'm going to walk
into one of these little pods
down the hall because all
of a sudden, the sun
is coming in here
in this room like crazy.
But I'll wait a second.
Thank you so much, Christina.
I was curious just to start
off a question about getting
to make packages and having
that be a big part of your role
sounds awesome.
And I was just curious to
learn a little bit more
about the team that you're on.
Yeah.
So I'm in a pretty small team.
There are four of us on my team.
And we do the modularity-ish
of the package building here
at GSK at least for our internal
use and to some external ones.
There are other people
in our community
who help with other projects
like the Admiral project--
an admiral package.
There are people in our
department who do that,
but I am not one
of those people.
I do other pharmaverse things.
I currently hold--
within the pharmaverse,
I'm the person who writes
packages to deal with metadata.
I don't know how this
has become my life.
It was an accident.
It wasn't like I love metadata.
So I have three primary
packages that I maintain
within the pharmaverse,
metacore which
deals with metadata
around data sets,
metatools which uses that
metadata to do fun automation
stuff, and t-format which deals
with metadata around formatting
tables.
So that's all of
the metadata I hold
in my world of
pharma-based metadata.
But that is-- so that's like me.
And then my team is really--
they're-- primarily me and
Becca Krauss who's on-- who does
safety graphics and [INAUDIBLE]
who does [INAUDIBLE]..
So there's-- all of us have
our own packages as well.
But those are the ones
that we maintain right now.
Cool.
I think that was-- sorry,
that was a very indirect answer,
Rachael.
It's the end my day.
This is my excuse.
That was helpful
and thank you.
I made my journey down the
hall into this new room
where the sun wasn't
in my face there.
Thank you so much, Christina.
And I was just also
wondering listening
to share about the
different packages,
how does the team decide what
to work on or prioritizing?
At the moment, the
priority has really
been developing a pipeline
for us that's usable.
For us, the clock is
ticking for how long
we're going to keep using SAS.
Well, that's not true.
We might always use that.
But we want a fully
developed pipeline for R.
And so really,
like how I started
and how it's gone
from this point is
looking at this
pipeline and saying,
what do we need in order to
have the things that we need?
If we have all of these
things, we can report a study.
And so really that was
where the target is for us.
And specifically,
for me and my team,
we try to identify where there's
not already a lot of people
doing the same thing.
There's influx of people into
pharma building R packages
right now.
And there's a lot of
people doing things that
do calculations for instance.
And we're not necessarily--
I came to this role,
came into this world
by being a clinical
statistician.
I used to be the person who's
designed sample sized studies.
And then I needed some things.
And I was like, I'm going
to build a Shiny app to do
some sample size things for me.
And over time I became
that a Shiny person
who then built some packages.
And I then--
I more fell into this
role that was like,
I am, today, going to
be a data scientist.
It was really based on my
own needs and the needs
of people around me.
So that's how I fell in here.
And so because I'm not
a clinical programmer,
I really do my best to
not take over some--
within the pharma space, some
of the reporting and stuff--
I guess, this is a very--
sorry, I'm very pharma
jargony right now.
Basically, within-- when you're
reporting a clinical trial,
there's two people who do the
database-- the data set things
in terms of job, career, people.
It's clinical programmers
and statisticians
or clinical statisticians.
The statisticians
tend to maybe run
the final analysis, the
main big one that tells you
whether the study works.
But there's a whole
bunch of things
that you need to do like,
get the number of people
in the study, check that--
look at all the
safety, adverse events,
and calculate the number
of adverse events there
which are not really doing
traditional statistics.
They're more like means,
standard deviations,
all of the data sets cleaning
up, all of that sort of stuff.
And that's traditionally
been done by someone
called a clinical programmer.
And so I have never been
one of those people.
And so I always say I
just play one on TV.
But I tried to leave the--
and my group isn't full of
people who were that role.
So I try to leave the stuff
where it's like you need really
in-depth knowledge to understand
how particular things are
calculated and data sets.
The people who work clinical
programmers are really good
at that because they can bring
that knowledge to the table,
because I can't.
That's why I tend to
avoid doing those things
and try to focus more on things
where I can add value that way,
so.
Thank you.
And I see there's
a lot of people
who have joined us since I first
said this in the beginning.
So I just want to
remind everybody--
I see a lot of questions
starting to come in now.
But if you just join, welcome.
Thanks for joining us.
You can ask questions using
a Slido link if you want
to ask anything anonymously.
And we'll share that again
in the chat in a second.
But feel free to just raise
your hand to jump in as well.
I see Alan you just recently
put a question to the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, that was a good
coffee timing there.
So Christina, I think I was
typing this at the same time
you were starting to describe
those other folks who
were downstream of
the work you're doing.
And I was just
interested in what
that collaboration is like.
Are they-- if you think about
your most direct customers,
are they those clinical
programmers and others
who are on the study
specific teams,
or do you have a different--
what's the mode of interaction
there?
And how do you figure out
who to be responsive to
and when-- as
studies come along,
as study milestones are
hit, and things like that?
Is that stuff you're engaged in,
or are you a little bit removed
from the study conduct itself?
I would say yes to everything.
So on one level, I'm
a little bit engaged--
removed from it and that I--
anything that I'm actively
building hopefully
isn't also being
used in a trial.
We try our best not
to be trying to fly
a machine while building it.
That seems not ideal.
So we don't tend to do that.
But at the same time,
those clinical programmers
are oftentimes the
people who I work--
I work with them a lot.
And they are major
customers for me
because if I write functions
that they don't understand
how they're going to
work together and fit
and they don't
make sense to them
and don't solve problems
that they're having, they are
useless.
I might as well have drawn
a picture for myself.
That maybe was probably
would have been easier.
But they're also not my
only customers because--
depending on what I'm doing.
So for my data set,
metadata packages,
they actually basically
are my only customers.
But for the table
formatting one,
there are other people
who are even further down
the line than, for instance,
clinical programmer,
because a clinical programmer
makes all these tables to hand
over to somebody else called a
medical writer who then writes
the clinical study report
that goes to the FDA.
And so those people become--
are also my customers
because they have needs
like we need to ensure that
the typeface meets the FDA
requirements,
because it turns out
the FDA only accepts
five different fonts
and that the margins have
to be very particular.
And there's all sorts of rules
that they know and I do not.
And so they are my
customers from that.
And are the things
that I'm making still,
do they still meet those needs?
Got it.
Cool.
Thank you.
Yeah, of course.
Hey, Marlene.
I see you have your
hand raised, too.
Do you want to jump in?
Heck yeah, I do.
Good morning, everyone--
or I don't know what part
of the world you're in.
It may not be morning, but
it's morning where I'm at.
Christina, thanks for joining
us and co-hosting with Rachael.
I am super thrilled
for you because I
feel like you're in a
place that I want to be at.
So I'm having a little
bit of envy here.
But my question
stems from a twofold.
I'm trying to figure
out, structurally, where
you sit-in your organization.
So are you under IT informatics?
Are you somewhere else?
Also what was the road like
to get to that position
and to have a pipeline
set up, because I'm
the only R user in my company.
And right now, I'm in--
I'm scrambling to build kind of
a sandbox playground VM place
to start up some of
this work and then
to start-- to have to be the
pied piper for other analysts
and scientists in the company
to start to play with R
and find a safe space
to work and then
eventually, maybe
be in that position
where I write
packages like you do.
Yeah.
So my history-- so
I sit within what's
a department called
biostatistics.
So in these massive
pharma companies,
you usually have a department
full of statisticians
and clinical programmers who do
the reporting out of the study
and the designing of the study.
So that's the department
that we sit-in.
And we grew out of a need
to support that department,
building out things like--
we actually started with really
supporting the statisticians
primarily and doing--
building tools for them
to help design trials.
That was the need that I had
when I was a statistician.
And so that ended
up being the tool
that I built with
others, not just me.
We have some really
brilliant statisticians here
who know math more than I do.
And they're very
good at the math.
But maybe, they don't know
how to be-- how always to--
we are a big department.
GSK is a big company
that I don't even
know how many
statisticians there
are but many, probably at
least 200 to 300 or something.
The statistician who knows how
to do a particular analysis
type or like for trial design
can't sit with all 200 people
when they need help.
So we started building out
some Shiny apps to help them--
to help people design it.
So that is how we started.
We, being my entire
department, because I have--
our department is not very old.
It's been around, God, four or
five-- four years, five years.
So we're like a
fairly new department
within our sub department
with my larger biostatistics
department.
And I've been around
since the beginning.
So that's how our
department largely started.
And then as we started building
those sorts of tools, some
of the-- there is a
request to, hey, we
want to move to trying R for
clinical study reporting.
And so as we started
to move to that,
that's how we started building
packages for that need.
And it was really--
that's more or less how
it happened for both me
personally, and me, as a--
we as a whole sub department.
Thank you.
MARLENE: Cool.
Thank you, yeah.
I want to make sure to get to
some of the anonymous questions
over on Slido, too.
So I'm going to go
jump back and forth.
But I see one over
there was, years ago,
GSK had a very specific
extensive SAS macro system.
It said, it even had a
name which I now forget.
Is the corp now
doing this with R?
So I don't know what
the grand vision is.
I am not puppet master.
But I would say we
are really trying
to focus as much as possible as
doing stuff in the open source.
So I think a lot of the
extensive macro system
that we currently
have today, which
I don't know if I'm
allowed to say the name of,
I don't know what the rules are.
I'm not going to
say the name of it,
because you didn't, so
just keep it that way.
It's like the one that
shall not be named.
That macro system--
a lot of what it does
are things that Admiral and
other pharmaverse packages are
taking into place and doing.
And really, our goal as
like the larger pharmaverse
is to do our best not just at
GSK but other pharma companies
to as much as we can open
source all of these kind
of complex macro systems into
things that everybody can use.
It makes it easier for everyone.
And when we're hiring
people for instance,
we can hire someone and
then be like, yes, I
have used all of
these pharma specific,
R packages because
I come from pharma.
And we don't have to spend
six months or whatever
training them for our
complex macro system.
Instead, it's more like, here
are some of our processes,
but you should feel comfortable
with most of these things
because you've probably been
somewhat exposed to them.
So that's one of
the reasons that GSK
is looking at
pharmaverse and helping
in [INAUDIBLE] that
involved in that way because
of those sorts of spaces.
Thank you.
And just for
clarification because I
think this was another
earlier question
was what actually
is the pharmaverse.
Oh, so sorry.
I'm--
RACHAEL: No, no worries.
This is when you go-- when you
spend too much time in pharma,
we all have so much jargon.
And we say it to
each other so much
that we forget what
jargon even is.
And I am so--
I think we all all do that.
I do that here.
--so, sorry.
So yes, the
pharmaverse is a group
of packages that
is all open source.
Thank you, Eric.
You just put, there's
a website just for it.
But basically, it's
a series of packages
that really look on
building pharma end to end,
because the pharma workflow
is somewhat standardized.
The FDA and the EMA
have requirements.
They're like, you need
to have a data set
and it's called
an atom data set.
And it looks exactly like this.
And you're like, OK, great.
And so there's not like
everyone does their own thing
and gets to be creative about
how that data set works.
If you do that, the
FDA will be like,
no, thank you, go away, make
the thing I've told you to make.
So because there's-- and
with standardization can come
automation and
overall improvements.
So that means that
we're really--
and the pharmaverse reverse
is trying to get some of that
automation, and
that time saving,
and stuff like that
possible because you--
because of that.
So that is what
the pharmaverse it.
Cool.
Thank you.
We're going to make through
like five questions, Rachael.
And I'm so sorry.
No, this is great.
And I love seeing everybody
helping out in the chat,
too, and sharing links as well.
Thanks, Eric.
I see, Eric, you had a
question earlier, too.
Do you want to jump in?
Be glad to great to hear
from you again, Christina.
I'm curious, back to your
discussion about obviously open
source work, how does your team
prioritize that type of work
versus your more quote, unquote,
"day-to-day responsibilities"
at GSK?
And what is leadership
buy and then
to give your team
support to work on
say the pharmaverse
or other sets
that are happening
in the industry,
because I think it's
an exciting trend.
But admittedly, I do see
some pockets of industry
slow on the uptake on this being
a really core importance here.
Just curious, your
thoughts on that.
Yeah.
So thankfully, I work
under Andy Nichols
who I don't know-- most people
probably won't know that name.
But yeah, Eric knows that name
which is important someone
does.
He helps lead-- there's the
thing called the R validation
hub.
He very much loves R
and the open source.
And so we had to do a
lot of groundwork laying.
But now, most of
my time is actually
spent on dealing stuff-- dealing
with stuff in the open source.
I would say 80% of my time
is doing stuff like that
and building packages
for the open source
and then sometimes building
internal like compendium
packages to make those
open source packages
work for us internally.
But I would say, it's largely
open source work is what I do.
But that's not necessarily
how it started out.
But I think having
leadership like having
Andy do all of the talking to be
like, open source is important,
has been great.
So have yourself and Andy
is my top recommendation.
Outside of having yourself
an Andy, I think for us--
the pharmaverse has
been really great,
because it has been
a collaboration where
other pharma companies have
also said it's important.
And so you're able to--
no one wants to be the only one
out there putting open store
stuff out.
That feels very
uncomfortable when
you're like standing alone in
the wilderness and you're like,
I am alone.
But as everyone started
to put stuff together,
now we can really
talk to our leadership
like, it's important
to use open source,
because if we don't
do it and if our voice
doesn't get heard
here, sometimes it
means that the way we
want things to be done
might not be done that way,
because somebody else built it.
And now, that's really popular.
And that other person
built it a while ago.
And everyone uses that.
And it can be hard
to change course,
change your ship
that's already--
I don't know some ship
analogy about moving ships.
And so that is why I
think that's generally
the argument that we use when
talking about the open source.
And also, you'll
hear something--
I can't remember
the exact phrase
but pharma, my general career
path, we're not an IT company.
The day GSK becomes
an IT company
is the day I'm like,
please, this is bad.
So we don't want to
be an IT company.
We want to deliver people,
make drugs, and help
people, live better lives.
That's our goal as
a pharma company,
not to become an IT company.
So us developing software
that helps everyone
deliver on the thing that
we're all supposed to be doing.
It's easier to argue
that that's not
intellectual property
for us because
our intellectual property tends
to be things like molecules.
And that's a thing that we
make, and that's what we do.
We don't-- we're
not an IP company.
And so that's the other
thing to just where we
are in in the world of stuff.
I see a lot of excitement
around the pharmaverse
and in the chat right now
Libby and John talking
about other industries
have something similar.
John, do you want to jump in?
Really, thank you.
So Christina, Libby, and I,
and a lot of other people
have been talking about
trying to do something that's
inspired by the pharmaverse
but more for human resources
and trying to pull together
people in different companies
to build packages together.
We have far less
standardization.
And honestly, HR
analytics is pretty poor.
So anything that can
help raise the bar
would be really good at 95%
of the places or probably 99%.
So any suggestions
on how to kick
start a movement of
getting people together
or any lessons learned from
the pharmaverse about what
we should do or avoid?
I don't personally
believe you need to have
a big splash in order to start.
I think if you wait for
a big beautiful website
and everything to be working
before you try and get
into anything, you're going to
just be waiting in a circle.
So I firmly believe
finding some friends
and start developing packages
with them is a great choice.
And it doesn't have
to be a huge number.
Honestly, I wasn't necessarily
run for the whole origin
story of the pharmaverse.
But part of it grew
out of something
like Michael Ruemmler
and Michael--
and Mike Stackhouse, two people
who are not here and probably
you don't know.
But basically,
they were like, we
should build some
packages together.
And I was like, OK.
And they were like,
Christina, come help.
And I was like, OK.
And I built a package
for them, with Atorus,
so a different company that is
not even a big pharma to CRO.
So we're like we and a CRO
built a package or two together.
And then the Mikes we're
having more conversations
with other people.
And all of a sudden, there
is a beautiful website.
And I was like, wow,
everything's coming together.
And so to some extent, it's
just like talking to people
and then starting
to build stuff.
Eventually, you'll
have enough stuff
that you will have
your own verse.
But I highly recommend starting.
And in terms of the things
aren't standard, what do you do
and how do you start,
sometimes a nice starting place
is a package that helps
standardize stuff.
Metadata is not really in a
standard format in pharma.
Everyone has their own way
of holding this metadata.
It gets standardized to a
thing called a define XML,
but that's only right
at the end of the day.
Typically, that defined XML
comes together, as you're
like sending the thing the FDA.
It's not like that's--
it's not ready at the beginning.
And so one of the
first packages that I
built as part of the
pharmaverse was this package
called metacore.
As I said, I'm like--
I hold many metadata
things, don't know why.
But part of the reason was
we wanted to build automation
off this metadata.
But everyone held it in
a different Excel format,
typically, or like
it was in a database.
But it was their own way.
They designed it their way.
It's different for everybody.
So we needed to have a
thing that we could all
look at and be like,
this is the thing,
and we all use this thing,
and this is how it works.
So like what metacore came for
us is just like an R6 object.
It's just an object.
It's the most boring package
in the whole wide world.
It does almost new things.
It sits there and
you can poke at it.
But like, that's it?
But that enabled additional
automation to be run off.
So then we have a
different package
called metatools that does
a lot of this automation.
But the first step
was getting that thing
we could all agree on was
like the thing we were using.
And it doesn't
have to be perfect.
It's a great point.
Thank you, Christina.
So we have a ton of questions
here on Slido as well
that I see coming through it.
So one anonymous one
was, the learning curve
is steep from cozy
SAS programming
to pharmaverse or
a read open source.
Any suggestions for newbies
transitioning from SAS
to R and Python?
My first suggestion
is like try
doing a thing that
you generally know
how to do that thing intact.
If you don't run AIML models
in SAS, don't be like,
I'm going to learn R and
start with AIML models
because that's a thing
I've always wanted.
I know it's a thing you--
even if you want to
get there eventually,
it can be helpful to start
in a place where like,
I know what this data set
should look like at the end.
So I'm going to do
something similar.
So that's my first
general recommendation.
But I would also say
like, I really like
the R for Data Science book.
I think that one's really good.
We are trying to-- we being the
people of the pharmaverse are
trying to pull out some
sample like sample code used
to build a standard ADSL
You're saying you're
coming from SAS.
So I'm going to use
pharma words at you
like a standard data set.
So you can start doing things
that you are familiar with.
But those are my
general suggestions.
At some point, you
just got to do it.
And that will make-- it
will get easier with time
because it's December 1.
I'll also recommend
like advent of code.
It's a thing I like to do.
The questions get really
hard towards the end.
And so if you don't-- can't
do them in R, don't worry,
I can't do them in R either,
but just practicing problems.
I think going from SAS can
be hard because it's not
an object-oriented language.
Sorry, if you can
see my cat behind me.
I'm sorry if you can hear him.
He's decided now.
We love having cats
join the Hangouts, too.
See if they want
to jump up the--
He's calling for his people.
Anyway, but yeah, SAS
is not object-oriented.
And I think getting
over that first hurdle
of like having an
object-oriented language
is the hardest.
But then it does get
easier after that.
And I see lots of
people posting links.
Look at other people's links.
They seem great.
I really like that.
Don't start with AIML
models there, too.
It's just reminding me,
Travis, of your LinkedIn post
yesterday about Spotify wrapped
as the most popular data
science right now, just
counting how many times you
listen to something.
Travis, I see you asked
a question a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Hey, Christina.
I have a question about
how you access data.
So like one of these
boring admin questions
but knowing how a lot of-- so
for those not in pharma, there
are some software
giants in the space that
provide solutions to make
electronic case report
forms possible.
So at the clinic or wherever
your clinical trial is being
facilitated, people have to
enter into an interface like,
this patient had this
disorder and this event
happened on this day.
So there's companies that are
called things like metadata,
and viva, and inform.
And the way they
deliver out data
is typically not by way of
giving you access to an API
or keys to a database.
Rather, they have modules that
do nefarious things like email
data to you.
Have you all
encountered a better
way of making this
happen, because it's
one part of the data stack
in pharma that feels woefully
behind the times.
Are you all hitting like
a research data warehouse
or something more fancy
than just the nastiness
of unsecured data transfer?
So short answer, no.
Long answer, GSK has
a lovely department
called Data Management
that manages that data
and hands it to us in
biostatistics as SDTM data.
So because we get SDTM data--
and that's how our
departments work.
And my job-- back
to priority, how
does the priorities of what
packages get made for us today
largely set on what
my department needs.
My department doesn't have
to worry about yucky data
formats to SDTM or
trying to get those
sorts of things from an
eCRF into an SDTM, which--
so that is why I don't do that.
And that's why we've
not looked at it yet.
That's not a no ever.
It's just a thankfully
it's not been my problem,
but I sympathize.
Yeah, fair enough.
Yeah.
I'm interested because a
lot of these data managers
are now being rebranded as
clinical data scientists,
I think is the new phrase
that's it's going around.
So is that happening
at GSK, too?
Because you do more of
these semi-complicated data
engineering things.
I've heard the
name bandied around.
I don't know if it's like a--
going to be a GSK thing or
not or has been a GSK thing.
Honestly, so many people are
changing their name titles
to data scientists now.
I don't always keep it straight.
It's a cool club.
Great.
It's a great club.
Everyone can be in the club.
I'm not gatekeeping the club.
I just don't remember who has
joined the club this week.
So yeah, that's my question.
Sorry, I don't have
more better answer.
No, that's fine.
Thank you.
Billy, I see you put a
few questions into the chat
as well.
Do you want to jump in next?
Oh, Bill says no.
I think one of the
questions was, Christina,
if this is happening
across GSK globally
or if it's your team is
also US-based or UK-based.
Oh, yeah.
So as I said maybe earlier
when very few people were on,
despite my very American
accent, I live in the UK.
It's dark outside.
It's the end of my day.
So I'm blaming
everything on the fact
that it's almost-- it's 5:30.
I'm checked out.
So yes, no, we are--
we're doing this globally.
GSK is one global company.
So we as the biostatistics
department for all of GSK
support all of GSK.
My department is
quite spread out
despite being not very many
people, my little group.
So my little group is
really like four people.
And we are spread from
London to Seattle.
And so we cover a lot
of time zones for that.
And yeah, we work for all of the
biostatistics department in GSK
but also in other departments
within GSK as well.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you.
Going back to some of
the Slido questions,
when you were talking about
tables in the beginning,
someone asked, could you explain
how tables and R specifically
relate to the work
being done by GSK?
Maybe a few examples
or real use cases.
Yeah.
So tables-- when I
talk about tables,
when I was talking
about tables then--
sorry, my cat is now trying
to climb out the window that
is closed, very strange.
He doesn't normally do that.
Anyway, desperate
times, I guess.
So when I talk about
tables, I talk--
I mean demographics table
as in the number of people
who are goes male,
female, and goes,
here's the age cut, that
like mean age, max age,
mean age, what--
by treatment.
So it is like the standard.
It's like a standard.
It's different
for every company.
But it is a table
that we give out
for every study that
has ever run at GSK,
or you can have specifics
for like the table that
is for your particular
stats analysis
for your particular study.
But when I talk about tables,
I mean like that sort of table.
And that table we can create
in R cannot create in R--
it doesn't really matter--
and then needs to get formatted
in a very specific way
to meet those medical writing
requirements that I was talking
about before, where
they're like, it needs
to have these particular
margins, this particular font,
this is how we want it to look
to fit with our standards.
And so that is--
that's kind of the
tables we tend--
I tend to talk about.
And this year with my team,
we developed a package
that takes something called an
analysis results data, which
is a long skinny
data standard that
see this is currently piloting.
But basically,
the idea is rather
than having everybody-- because
what happens for the most part
today, I won't say
through all of pharma
but through most of pharma,
is that a clinical programmer
maybe their job today is
to make a demographics
table for their study.
So they're going to make
this demographics table.
They're going to do all the
calculations that they need
in order to get the end that
the number of people who
are over 65, and the number
of people who are under 65,
and all sorts of things,
the average weight,
the percentage of people who are
over 65, whatever by treatment,
they'll make that table.
Then somebody else comes
in and QCs that table.
But when they're QC-ing that
table, they might be like,
oh, all the numbers look
good but the spaces are off.
Now, I'm going to spend two
hours arguing with spaces, yay.
And everyone has a bad
time, so we don't want that.
That seems bad.
So the analysis
results that idea
is that rather than having
to QC a formatted thing,
you can QC the analysis
results metadata which
is long and skinny.
And the point is it's much
easier to QC, you can just
put all your ends and
rows and percents and rows
and make it tidy
data, everything
is good for everybody,
But then at the end of the
day, the medical writers still
do want a thing that looks like
a table that's easy to read,
or the clinician who's
trying to understand,
we've run this study,
the stats say this thing.
But they need-- clinicians
look at things to understand
what happened in the study.
So we need to make
it so easy for them.
So one of the things that we
did is create this package
that extracts some of that
formatting into metadata so
that the clinical
programmer can just
create a long and skinny
data set, call their job done
and dusted.
And the metadata sits elsewhere.
The metadata can be
created when you create
these mock tables which is--
so sorry for anyone
who's not in pharma.
This is such a pharma talk.
But basically, before
you start the study,
you draw out a picture.
And you're like, I want
a demographics table
that looks like this picture.
And then-- so then the
clinical programmer
has to do a thing that
looks like that picture.
But our idea is rather
than have it as a picture,
have it as metadata.
And then the clinical
programmer just
makes something long and skinny.
And then because you wrote the
metadata to draw your picture,
it will make your picture.
And you will be happy because it
will be exactly what you said.
And so that's how it
works if that makes any--
trying to explain code
in abstract is hard.
So that's our tabling package.
It really is more
table and formatting.
And yeah when, we
talk about tables,
it's just like the
demographic table
that the clinician will look
at or the medical writer.
Thank you.
And don't worry about the
pharma specific stuff.
I see John, thank you,
said, knowing nothing
about the industry, it's
still very interesting.
I'm glad.
I see a few other anonymous
questions over on Slido.
And one was, I'm assuming you
look for open source talent
when hiring.
Has this profile
changed over the years?
Our department is
not that old so yes.
But the years that we've
been looking are slim.
So it's more that--
our department's
five-ish years old.
The people we have
hired in have mostly
been like people who
had other open source
packages particularly
in the pharma space,
because they were like, you,
you clearly do this thing,
seems great.
And they've been great, and
I've loved to work with them.
So I would say yes.
Has it-- I can't--
there's not been enough
years to say it's changed.
Thank you.
I see so many helpful links and
comments shared in the chat,
too.
So I just wanted to
remember to say this
because sometimes people ask.
You can save the
chats if you want,
if you use the three dots
on the right hand side.
You can save the
chat there, too.
Just want to let everyone know
when I see all those links.
I try to collect them
all and share them.
But if you need them right
away, they're there are.
Another anonymous question
was, is any collaboration
with the FDA or
other agencies being
done to adopt more
R-based workflows?
So yes.
There are a variety
of working groups.
I am not personally
on any of them
where the FDA also sits
on the working group.
For instance-- and other
collaborations have happened.
For instance, there
was an R submission
that they submitted a
pilot study into the FDA.
But it was a pilot study.
It wasn't real, anything.
It wasn't real data.
It was in the right
format but it's--
thank you, Eric.
And so those sorts of working
groups and how it's being done,
and the pilot study, the
FDA was happy to review it.
They spent their
time doing things
like they would have reviewed a
real study, which we definitely
couldn't have done
without them being
totally willing to do that.
But yeah.
I'm not on-- so yes.
But also they're not like--
Eric, you can correct
me if I'm wrong.
I'm now pulling you into this.
They don't tend to be on a
huge number of working groups.
And they don't--
I have not seen them release
any R packages whether like,
this is what we're
doing to actively help.
They want to help us as in
the larger pharma community.
But they're also not
building a lot of stuff.
I don't know.
Eric, that might be wrong.
You're not [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Most of that is
definitely correct.
Although, we are making sure
that the code or products we're
developing are in the open
so that our pharmas can
use those the way they see fit.
And where we're at
currently is in pilot 2
with so many nice Shiny apps
in the FDA's submission portal.
And that will be-- obviously
all the code that we're
doing is open source
right now, I'll
put a link then and get up as
soon as I stop chatting here.
But in terms of people
that want to get involved
with that effort,
the best place to go
would probably be our GitHub
repos and file an issue
and say you'd like
to be a part of it.
And we'll make sure our
leads for the working group
get you involved in.
But it's an exciting
time right now.
And it does move slow sometimes.
But we've made a lot of progress
in the last couple years,
compared we were before.
So it's pretty exciting.
So Bill, I see
your hands raised.
You want to jump in?
Yeah.
First, am I on?
Yes, you are.
Yep.
I don't get this stuff.
Anyway, first,
Christina, thank you
very much for your work over
the R and pharma conference.
It was really great.
So I appreciate that.
And I think Eric, too I
don't know the other guys.
But I have this question
that I've posted many times.
So pharma-- sorry to
non-pharma people,
they're like lemmings even
more than anything else.
If one person does something,
then they will follow.
So the key event--
the key over the cliff
event is the exception--
the acceptance of a submission
by the FDA from some
therapeutic area is--
so I like to think
that might be oncology.
Who's in the lead here
that you can see, or is
or is there any lead anywhere?
Because there's a
lot of resistance
internally by many
clinical data,
data management biostat things.
That's my question.
I would say.
It's hard to say.
I don't have a real clear
like, this is definitely
going to happen this way.
I also think-- it's a--
yes, the answer is I don't know.
I don't know who's winning.
But I think it might--
things like the
Admiral packages where
there's Admiral specific
to a particular thing--
there's an Admiral onco.
There's an Admiral
virology, like yeah.
There's a couple of Admiral
specific ones that I think,
those are a great start.
I feel like--
I don't know exactly
where the change will be.
I think it's going to
be more slowly over time
than one particular section,
switching everybody over.
I think, at least,
how the GSK approach
is with choosing SAS
versus R when you're
trying to do
something is largely
whatever the programmers
feel comfortable with.
Our goal, part of our goal of
moving to R is getting to--
making it so that people--
there are a lot of
new grads and things
who are coming up who like
only learn R in grad school.
And so we want people to use
what they're comfortable with.
And so to some extent, that's
one of the many reasons
we use R. We like R for a
large variety of [INAUDIBLE]..
But also, it's what people know.
So I feel like, at
least from what I
think I see in our
department, it's
going to be like
this clinical study,
like clinical-- this
programmer who's
running this study
for submission
feels really comfortable in R.
They've done a lot of R stuff.
They love R. So they're going
to push their team to all use R.
And then those are
submissions that--
we've started to prepare
a submission in R
where the production is R
and QCs in SAS to the FDA.
But that was largely
spearheaded by people
who felt comfortable
doing things in R. Yes
and I saw you laughing when
I said the QC is done in SAS,
because we are pharma
and still risk averse.
So don't you worry, we're
not-- we're not there yet.
Thank you, Christina.
I see Daniel, you also had
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure, yeah.
Hey, it's great to hear
all this great stuff.
I do not work in pharma.
I work in transportation.
A lot of this is very new to me.
And some of the strategies that
you mentioned are new to me
as well.
And it might be naive
question, but I'm
interested to hear
a little bit more
about the interaction between
the metadata tables that you're
responsible for and the
downstream work that
involves those.
So just thinking about
the critical tables
with content from the studies,
the users, or the participants,
and all the other information
and how that relates
to the metadata, and
what that actually looks
like for the
downstream analysts.
How do they put
the two together?
Like what do you pass to
them, that kind of thing.
So this is like one
of our newer R packages.
So it is something
that like, I maintain
my team helped me build.
I couldn't have built it
without Ellis and Becca,
so just to give everyone
credit as the lead thing.
But also part of what we built
is based off a very pharma
specific workflow.
So just like I'm going
to put it out there.
And in pharma, we do a thing
where you make a table that is
full of nothing but
X's, where you're like,
this should be treatment,
this should be placebo,
this is the label, and then
looks like I want this to go
to xx.x because I
want it to go to one--
I want it rounded
only once, or like--
so you do this whole thing.
You draw out oftentimes,
sometimes in Excel,
sometimes in Word, the thing
you want it to look like.
And that's what's
called your mock.
So what we've done
is we've basically
made it so that this T format
package is a package where
you can put this metadata in
to say like, I want things
that are labeled and for
instance, to be rounded
to nothing.
You just want no decimal places.
But I want things
that are labeled
as mean, that are part of,
I don't know, the group age
to be rounded like this.
And you put it all in.
That then-- so that's
just an R script
where you can put
all this metadata in.
Our grand vision, although
we're not there yet,
because time and the limited
number of people and resources,
is to have that right
out to a JSON file.
It kind of looks
like a JSON now.
We just pretend in
our heart it is.
When in reality, it's
just an R object.
And that R object
is then what's used
whenever you have the data.
So the data has to get into
this semi-standard format called
an analysis results data, which
is just tidy data honestly.
You could use any
tidy data, data
set as long as it's long
and skinny like that.
And so the plan would be that
the clinical programmer just
makes that data set.
And then they can--
we can store the metadata,
which is in our pretend JSON
but is now just an R object.
And you can just--
it's basically kind
of plug and play.
So you can put-- if you
have a really standard table
for instance, you can use the
same metadata over, and over,
and over again and just
swap out the data sets.
You can go as many
times as you like.
And we'll make-- at the
moment, it goes out to DT,
probably keep that forever
because DT is great.
Like Rich has done
a really good job.
It makes all the
things that we want it
to look like for the most part.
And we've had to work
with Rich a little bit
in order to get things--
so there are some additional
things that we've needed.
And Ellis worked
with Rich in order
to get it to write out
to Word for instance,
which was important for us.
And he did that and
that was amazing.
And so it's-- we work
with people like Rich to--
our goal as a GSK
department largely
is to not build and
maintain everything
but to work with great fit
tools that already exist.
So yeah, that was--
So that's how we
would see it work
is that once you have
this [INAUDIBLE] object,
it can go to all of
the things you want.
It can go to your PowerPoint
or it can you go to PDF.
It can go to Word.
It can go to RTF,
HTML, whatever.
And from our perspective, we
can hold the formatting metadata
in a pretend JSON and
then just apply it
to as many data sets as you
want it to be applied to.
That's really fascinating.
I will put in the chat
the thing-- actually,
I can do that.
I don't have the site off
the top of my head right
this second.
Eric, you've been really good.
Can you pull up the
T format website?
Do you know where--
do you have it?
I'm just asking you because
you might note that's--
I will get it shortly.
It's on the way.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah.
So Tplyr does something similar,
except it does the analysis
as well.
And our goal is to not
do-- to separate out
the analysis and the formatting.
Because oftentimes, you want to
change your mind on formatting.
There are times that you--
especially in pharma,
there are times
where you're presenting some
slides to someone or something.
And so you don't need it rounded
out to the exact right decimal.
Or because you're just
trying to tell a story.
Or, for instance, once you
finish the clinical study
report, send it to the
FDA, and all of the things,
you do need to publish it.
We publish these papers.
And so sometimes, journals are
like, we have p-value rules,
and your p-value needs to
be rounded differently.
And if you only save
the rounded p-value,
you can't round a rounded value.
Right.
So you might have to rerun
the analysis, which is bad.
We don't want to do that because
you have re-QC everything.
So our goal is to
separate out the analysis
and the formatting.
And so that's what kind
of T Format does do.
Thank you, Eric.
You're the best.
Thank you.
I know we have a
few minutes here,
so I want to check to
make sure I haven't
missed anybody's questions,
whether on Slido or in the Zoom
chat.
So feel free to just
raise your hand too
or unmute and jump in if there
are some burning questions you
want to make sure I answered.
But I will ask you
while we're waiting
to see who maybe
raises their hand
or what I miss, what is
something that you're
most excited about thinking
out to maybe the year ahead
in the pharma space or
open source in general?
I think in the
year ahead, the thing
that I'm starting
to see the most is
I really am starting to see this
complete end to end solution.
We're almost there, excluding
Travis's problem with things
that before they go into SDTM.
But that's not my
world, so in my head,
it's complete, even though
it's not complete for everyone.
But I get to care
about myself here.
So it's fine.
So depending on where
you start, end to end.
And I love to see that.
And so I think
that really will--
to some extent,
that will also start
making it easier for people
to do that transition.
I think one of the
things that has
been a barrier up
until today is that
without every single building
block in place in terms of we
need an all equivalent
for everything,
it can be hard to move into
that to be like, OK, we agree.
And we're willing to take
the leap and try on a study.
And sometimes, for
stuff, you know
you won't even need for
that particular study
or that particular moment.
But just to be able to say to
your leadership, don't worry.
That thing exists
if we need it, which
I don't think we
will, but we might,
can be helpful in terms
of getting leadership by.
Thank you, Christina.
And when I just asked if
there are any other questions,
I see one anonymous
one that came in.
And it was, if not
wrong during RN pharma,
someone mentioned that Roche--
and someone told me I've
been pronouncing Roche wrong,
so maybe correct
me-- is transitioning
to R entirely in 2023.
Is GSK or anyone in the
industry on the same path?
We are currently on the path
of choose your own adventure,
as I said, to let
people do what they want
and what works for them.
And so that is the GSK party
line and that is what I know.
So yeah.
I don't know of anyone
who's doing that quite that
extreme level.
I mean, Roche has been
to some extent more--
they've had some of
these tools longer.
They're starting to open source
more and more of their stuff.
But they've had R Tables for
a really long time, which has
been open source for a while.
But that's what they
use in build and great.
And so yeah.
I'm not surprised that
they're a little further ahead
than everybody
else in this space.
So--
One last question I'd
love to ask you is I
see a lot of your involvement
in RN pharma and conferences
and workshops that you've led.
If there are people
listening in who
want to get more involved
in the pharma community,
what do you think is the
best way to get started?
The best way to
get started is,
A, you have to choose what's
right for you I would say.
To Erick's point, if there's
a working group that you love,
make an issue.
And they probably
need your help.
If there's a package that you
love and want to be involved
in, ask the package maintainer.
This includes me.
I am the sole maintainer
on a lot of my packages.
And I have other
help from my group.
But sometimes, I'm the only
one who does the thing.
So if you are like, I have
looked at your packages,
and I also love metadata with
a deep and burning passion.
Or you don't, but you want
to help, I would love that.
Because I have one person.
And so yeah.
I would say contact people.
For the most part, in
the RN pharma space,
people are so open to
help and very receptive.
So I've yet to go up to
someone and been like, I
have a pull request for you.
And them be like, no, you don't.
Yeah.
Most people are like, thank you.
That's amazing.
So I would say
generally, it's really
an arms wide open community.
It's amazing Thank
you so much, Christina.
And if people do want to
get in touch with you,
is it through GitHub
that you prefer?
Or is LinkedIn better?
GitHub is great.
LinkedIn is good.
Another option is I am on--
there's a pharmaverse Slack,
so you can go on the
pharmaverse Slack.
I'm available there as well.
So I would say
whatever works best.
If you send me a message on
GitHub, that's probably-- like,
you need to put an issue on
one of my actual packages
for me to see it.
But you can also-- yeah,
LinkedIn or Slack are probably
the easiest ways to
get a hold of me,
unless you have an issue
on one of my packages
or want to be involved
in a very specific one.
And in which case, an
issue will be great.
Perfect.
I just put your LinkedIn
into the chat as well.
Thank you so much, Christina,
for joining us today
and sharing your experience.
Yes, thank you for having me.
And thank you, Eric,
for being my buddy
and doing links for me.
That was very helpful.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you for all the great
questions and resources
shared in the chat, too.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.